WITH KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS,
AND DANA PERINO.
WOMEN WORE BLACK.
MEN WORE PINS.
PEOPLE USED WORDS LIKE
INTERSECTIONAL GENDER PARITY.
>> WE WANT INTERSECTIONAL GENDER
NOTHING LIKE MESSING ON THE
CARPET.
THIS SCRIPT WAS SET.
A SHOW OF UNITY CONDEMNING
ABUSES MOST IN HOLLYWOOD HAD
IGNORED FOR DECADES.
IT'S ABOUT TIME.
I DON'T THINK I COULD STICK
BUT ONE FORM OF LOCKSTEP BECOMES
ANOTHER.
HOLLYWOOD THERAPY IS ALWAYS
PROJECTION, LECTURING US ON US
WHEN WHAT'S REALLY WRONG IS
HOLLYWOOD.
CONNIE BRITTON'S SHIRT READS
"POVERTY IS SEXIST."
IT MAKES NO SENSE TO INJECT
IDENTITY POLITICS INTO SHARED
ABUSED.
KEEP IT FROM BECOMING REAL, SAYS
THE GUY WHO WON.
SADLY HE WASN'T REFERRING TO
IRAN.
I THINK HE MEANT US BECAUSE
IRAN, VENEZUELA, THE USSR, CUBA.
THEY ARE ALWAYS THE LAST TO KNOW
OR CARE.
THEN CAME OPRAH.
A STRONG SPEECH DESIGNED TO
BRING MORAL CLARITY TO IN THE
MORAL TERRAIN.
>> FOR TOO LONG, WOMEN HAVE NOT
BEEN HEARD OR BELIEVED.
IF THEY DARED TO SPEAK THEIR
TRUTH TO THE POWER OF THOSE MEN,
HERE NOW TO KNOW THAT A NEW DAY
IS ON THE HORIZON.
>> Greg: EIGHT WENT ON.
THE TIME IS UP BUTTON DID NOT
APPLY TO HER.
WITH JEAN IS HAVING OPRAH ON.
EVEN NBC CALLED HER THE NEXT
PRESIDENT.
THAT SOUNDS FAMILIAR.
NOMINATE OPRAH.
SHE WINS.
I'M NOT KIDDING.
SKIP IT, GET TO THE POINT.
PUT OPRAH UP THERE.
YOU DON'T EVEN HOLD THE
ELECTION.
IT'S OVER.
OPRAH IS AN ICON WHO UNLIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Kimberly: A WOMAN RAN FOR
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND IF SHE WASN'T
SUCH A BAD CANDIDATE, SHE MAYBE
WOULD HAVE WON.
CONDOLEEZZA RICE WOULD HAVE DONE
BETTER.
>> Greg: SHOULD'VE BEEN OPRAH.
THAT'S THE BEST IDEA HOLLYWOOD
HAS.
MAYBE THE BEST WHEN THEY HAVE
LEFT.
I WATCHED, KIMBERLY, THE ENTIRE
SHOW.
I THOUGHT IT WAS BRILLIANT THAT
OPRAH CAME ON BECAUSE IT
OVERSHADOWED A LOT OF THE
>> Kimberly: LOW, THAT WAS
PROBABLY THE BIG PIVOTAL MOMENT
OF THE NIGHT.
YOU START ACROSS SOCIAL MEDIA
AND ALL THE BLOGS.
PEOPLE LOVED IT.
SHE LOOKED GREAT.
SHE SOUNDED FANTASTIC,
CONFIDENT, POISED.
CERTAIN OF HER MESSAGE.
IT WAS EXTERNALLY WELL-RECEIVED
BY ACHIEVING GENDER PARITY FOR
MEN AND WOMEN.
ONCE AGAIN, SHE IS WINNING.
>> Greg: DANA, WHEN I THINK
ABOUT THIS, I THINK OF THIS IS
THE MIRROR OF TRUMP.
IF THERE'S A CROWDED DEMOCRATIC
FIELD IN 2019, IF SHE IS UP ON
STAGE WITH 17 OTHER POLITICIANS,
SHE INSTANTLY GOES TO THE FRONT
BECAUSE SHE'S NOT A POLITICIAN.
SHE'S A BILLIONAIRE AND SHE IS
LIKE A HARD-CORE PERSUADER LIKE
TRUMP.
>> Dana: AND A BUSINESS WOMAN.
I THINK THE THING IS SHE DOESN'T
WANT TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
FRIENDS SAY SHE IS CONSIDERING
IT BUT I GUESS NOW WE'VE BROKEN
THE SEAL ON TAKING A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO POLITICS, I THINK
SHE WOULD BE AS GOOD A CANDIDATE
AS ANYONE ELSE.
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING HOW THE
DEMOCRATS WHO SUPPORTED
BERNIE SANDERS WOULD SUPPORT
OPRAH.
>> Greg: WELCOME BACK, JUAN.
HOW WAS JAMAICA?
>> EXCELLENT.
>> Greg: YOU MISSED SOME GREAT
WEATHER.
>> I MISSED YOU.
>> Jesse: DON'T LIE, JUAN.
>> Greg: THE DEMOCRATS WOULD
BE CRAZY NOT TO RECRUIT HER.
DANA SAYS WE HAVE BROKEN THE
SEAL ON THIS SO NOW IT'S LIKE
THE BIGGEST CELEBRITY BECOMES
THE PRESIDENT?
>> Dana: NO, SHE WOULDN'T BE
THE FIRST.
>> HER LONGTIME FRIEND STEDMAN
GRAHAM HAS SAID SHE WOULD DO IT.
BUT WHEN SHE WAS INTERVIEWED
WAS RIDICULOUS BECAUSE I KNOW
BUT NOW WITH DONALD TRUMP SHE
SAYS, WELL, MAYBE.
MAYBE THE DOORS OPEN BUT FOR ME,
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING?
SHE'S A TERRIFIC PERSONALITY.
I HAPPEN TO KNOW HER AND LIKE
HER VERY MUCH.
I JUST DON'T KNOW IF SHE WOULD
BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I THINK THE SAME THING ABOUT
RUNNING A BUSINESS IS HARDER
THAN RUNNING THE COUNTRY, RIGHT?
>> Jesse: SURE.
I LIKED HOW SELF-SATISFIED YOU
LOOK WHEN YOU ARE PLAYING THE
CLIPS OF YOURSELF.
LET SEE THAT LOOK AGAIN.
ALSO KNOCK OFF THE STUFF ABOUT
LAYOFF.
LISTEN, I WANT TO THE PEOPLE TO
PICK THE PRESIDENT.
I DON'T WANT THE PRESS TO FAKE
IT.
THE "DRAFT OPRAH" MOVEMENT SHOWS
SHE'S A SELF-MADE BILLIONAIRE,
INCREDIBLY CAPTIVATING.
SHE HAS WIDE APPEAL AS A BLACK
WHAT'S HER POSITION ON
NORTH KOREA?
DOES PRESIDENT OPRAH STRIKE FEAR
IN THE HEARTS OF ISIS?
WHAT DISHY THING ABOUT THE
BORDER POLICY?
>> Juan: SOUNDS LIKE YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT TRUMP A YEAR AGO.
>> Jesse: HE HAD BEEN DABBLING
IN POLICY FOR DECADES.
HE HAD BEEN WRITING ABOUT IT.
OPRAH IS MORE A VESSEL, AND EVEN
YOU WOULD HAVE TO ADMIT IT.
TRUMP KNEW EVERYTHING.
>> Jesse: I THINK TRUMP KNOWS
MORE ABOUT POLITICS AND POLICIES
AND OPRAH.
>> Greg: SPEAKING OF BUSINESS,
WEIGHT WATCHERS SHARES JUMPED
13% BECAUSE SHE OWNS 10%.
>> Kimberly: OKAY, WELL, GOOD.
WEIGHT WATCHERS HELPED A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
>> Greg: JUST BY MENTIONING
THEM.
IF I MENTION WEIGHT WATCHERS.
THEY DELIVER THE FOOD, DON'T
THEY?
>> Jesse: WHAT WAS THAT AGAIN?
>> Greg: WEIGHT WATCHERS.
>> Dana: I WRITE A THING TODAY
ABOUT HOW MEN ARE NOW BECOMING
THE SPOKESPEOPLE FOR THINGS LIKE
WEIGHT WATCHERS.
>> Kimberly: NUTRISYSTEM AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
I THINK SITTING UP A LITTLE BIT
BETTER MIGHT HELP.
YOU WATCH THE WHOLE THING.
>> Kimberly: I RESPONDED
POSITIVELY IN THE AFFIRMATIVE
FROM AN EMAIL FROM THE
PRODUCERS.
>> Greg: WHAT DID YOU THINK
ABOUT THE TONE?
>> Kimberly: THE WOMEN DRESSED
IN BLACK.
HE SEEMED A LITTLE BIT MORE LIKE
SOMBER, LITTLE BIT MORE, NOT AS
AT THE LINTON PEOPLE BEING
RAUCOUS.
IT WAS MORE LIKE, DIGNIFIED.
I THOUGHT IT WASN'T -- I THOUGHT
I WASN'T GOING TO LIKE IT.
I LIKED THE OPRAH THING.
I THOUGHT THE WOMEN LOOKED
BEAUTIFUL.
AT FIRST I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING
TO BE SOME KIND OF AGGRESSIVE
MOVEMENT BUT IT WASN'T.
IT WAS DIGNIFIED.
IT WAS FINE.
I DIDN'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT.
IT WAS ENTERTAINING.
I KEPT IT ON.
>> Greg: THEY INVITED TONYA
HARDING BECAUSE THEY MADE A
MOVIE ABOUT HER.
SHE WAS THERE, AND THEY KIND OF
PORTRAYED HER AS A FEMINIST ICON
BUT ALLEGEDLY DIDN'T SHE PLAN TO
ATTACK, WASN'T SHE PART OF THE
ATTACK?
>> Juan: YES.
>> Greg: NANCY CARRIGAN WAS A
VICTIM.
>> Greg: NANCY CARRIGAN WAS
KNEECAPPED.
>> Dana: A RELUCTANT
ACCOMPLICE.
>> Juan: WHAT STRIKES ME IS
THE CULTURE IS AHEAD OF THE
POLITICS IN AMERICA ALL OF A
SUDDEN.
EVERYTHING IS ABOUT THE CULTURE.
THE GOLDEN GLOBES, OPRAH, YOU
DON'T NEED TO REALLY KNOW
ANYTHING TO RUN FOR OFFICE.
WHAT?
THE WORLD HAS GONE CRAZY.
>> Greg: OR THE WORLD HAS
GOTTEN MORE AWESOME.
I'M GOING TO PLAY SOUND ON TAPE
OF THE HOST SETH MEYERS BECAUSE
NOBODY REMEMBERS BECAUSE OF
OPRAH.
HE ADDRESSES THE CRITICISM THAT
HOLLYWOOD IS A BUNCH OF ELITES.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE A ROOM OF
PRIVILEGED HOLLYWOOD ELITE AND
THAT'S FAIR BUT EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM KNOWS THAT HOLLYWOOD IS SO
MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
WHEN YOU ON A FILM SET, YOU MEET
HAIRDRESSERS AND CAMERA PEOPLE
AND SCRIPT SUPERVISORS.
MOST OF THE JOBS ON FILM SETS
ARE JOBS FOR PEOPLE WHO WORK
LONG, HARD HOURS.
THEY ARE AMERICAN DREAM JOBS.
THOSE PEOPLE AREN'T THERE THANKS
TO THEIR RICH DAD.
EXCEPT FOR THAT ONE P.A.
IT'S CLEAR NOW THAN EVER BEFORE
THAT THE WOMEN HAD TO WORK EVEN
HARDER.
>> Greg: JESSE, WHAT HE'S
DOING IS TAKING THE LITTLE
PEOPLE TO MAKE IT SO THAT THE
ELITES DON'T LOOK SO BAD.
LOOK.
WE HAVE HAIRSTYLISTS.
MAKEUP, CATERERS.
>> Jesse: MY BUTLER AND MY
DRIVER.
>> Greg: MY FOOTMAN.
>> Jesse: WHO WAS THE WOMAN ON
"THE VIEW" OR ONE OF THOSE
NBC COMES OUT AND PROMOTES THIS
WHOLE PRESIDENCY OF OPRAH.
BECAUSE SHE DID A "ME TOO"
SPEECH BUT NBC COVERED UP FOR
MATT LAUER AND THEN SPIKED THE
WEINSTEIN EXCLUSIVE.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT NBC
WANTS.
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
NBC TWEETED THAT OPRAH WAS GOING
TO BE THE NEXT PRESIDENT, AND
THEY PULLED THE TWEET.
>> Dana: NBC SAID THEY HAD
OUTSOURCED TWITTER THAT NIGHT TO
A THIRD-PARTY WHO HAD TWEETED
THAT SO THAT'S WHY THEY DELETED
IT.
I KNOW HOW TWITTER WORKS.
IT'S NOT THAT HARD AND YOU DON'T
HAVE TO HIRE A THIRD-PARTY.
>> Greg: NO, NO.
JUST HAVE A PARTY.
MY TWEETS ARE REMARKABLY MILD, I
BELIEVE.
WELL RECEIVED.
ACROSS THE BOARD, WELL RECEIVED.
THAT'S ENOUGH.